is one of senegal's rising opposition
leaders for others including the state
prosecutor
he's a rapist responsible for public
disorder after protests erupted
following his arrest last week
but sanko who's out on bail says the
allegations against him are politically
motivated
i have committed no crime we can
trust the justice system in the way the
case is being carried out against
me the tribunal is violating the law and
the procedures in order to sentence
political opponents
the prosecutor is not working for the
state
but the government deployed
extra security forces including the
military to end days of nationwide
demonstrations
rights groups say hundreds of people are
being detained the protests stopped
after president monkey sal
called for calm and dialogue in a
nationwide address
but songko is calling for more protests
what we are seeing right now is a
revolution but this is not a revolution
to overthrow
president makissa it's a smart
revolution
we need to organize local elections that
are two years overdue
then the parliament election in 2022 so
that the people can freely elect
a new leader in 2024.
describes himself as the
anti-establishment candidate for the
2024 presidential election
critical of senegal's relationship with
former colonial power france he accuses
the government of corruption favoring
french corporations
our relationship with friends like any
other countries need to be more
balanced it has to be a win-win
relationship
not a one-way relationship critics
say sanko's nationalist discourse is
dangerous
during the recent protests his
supporters are accused of burning and
looting
french supermarkets those looting are
doing it not because they support me
but because they need provisions these
are people that walk past the
supermarkets
unable to enter because they can't
afford it the looting shows
the failure of the state
scores were killed and many injured by
security forces since sunko's arrest
last wednesday
president maki sal blames the economic
fallout of the pandemic
for the unrest for sanko the crisis
calls for political change
those that died were 14 16 18 years old
they know their future is at stake in
honor to them
and all those that are political
prisoners of machisal
we can't give up the fight
but this is a movement that goes beyond
politics
it's a call by young senegalese tired of
being ignored
wanting to be heard sanko believes he is
the best suited
to carry that voice nicholas hawk al
jazeera dakar